Hi, I'm Maria Sharapova and I'm a professional tennis player.
And I can't wait to represent my country of Russia at the Summer Olympic Games.
What makes Summer Olympic Games special, personally for me,...
...is that I don't think there's anything like being part of the whole Olympics experience...
...where you're there simply to represent your country.
It meant a lot for me just to participate and even more to win a medal.
I think I'm mostly just looking forward to being part of all these different sports...
...and the parade and the opening ceremony.
And although we always travel and represent our countries in so many different sports,...
...to be in one place all of us together, I think that would be the most memorable experience.